welcome back earlier in the newscast  wayne newton shared with me a funny  story about his cameo in the movie vegas  vacation  he has been in hundreds of shows and  movies he has a singing career that  spanned more than six decades on stage  and of course he's seen las vegas grow  and here's what he had to say about the  city he calls home  it's really been a fun  trip  to watch  how las vegas has really  moved in the direction that it had to  to  to become what it is today  and i couldn't be more proud  of the city and to be a small part of  what it's become vegas is the place to  be baby  can't argue with that huh just a  reminder also we have some very special  giveaways as part of wayne newton week  wayne himself oz autographed some very  special items for example  that bright red handkerchief and we're  going to give away one of those a little  bit later on this week  there he is signing it just for proof